[Music]
even though UFOs are seen everywhere
over the desert over the ocean over
cities there's no way to predict when
and where they'll show up well no way
except one build or detonate a nuclear
weapon since the dawn of the atomic age
UFOs have been seen and photographed
during nuclear weapons tests and near
nuclear weapons facilities the Ark of
the Covenant is one of the most
mysterious artifacts in human history
The Ark a sacred chest made of wood and
covered in Gold has been missing since
587 BC its last known location was
Jerusalem somewhere under the Temple
Mount so what does that have to do with
UFOs well in 2011 a UFO is hovering over
the Dome of the Rock on the Temple mount
in Jerusalem it emitted a flash of light
then shot straight up and disappeared
into the night skies
this could be just a coincidence but it
could be that the craft was looking for
the ark the Ark of the Covenant is an
object of extreme religious importance
to over 2 billion people so why would a
UFO be looking for it well because it's
the most dangerous weapon of mass
destruction ever created
foreign
the Ark of the Covenant the story has
captivated us for over 2 000 years but
what is the ark really a container for
holy relics or as Indiana Jones said a
radio for talking to God or is it God's
ultimate Doomsday Machine a super weapon
for the righteous it's said to possess
tremendous power including the ability
to unleash plagues and natural disasters
as the legend goes an army that carries
the ark before it is Invincible or was
it something more mundane the story of
the Ark of the Covenant begins in the
book of Exodus and is mentioned over 200
times in the Bible it was carried by the
Israelites as they traveled through the
desert on their Journey to the promised
land the ark would fly into the sky
miles ahead of the Israelites and show
them the way it would protect them from
any dangers in their path it parted
Rivers created walls of fire caused the
mighty City walls of Jericho to crumble
and reduce mountains to dust the god
sounds like one hell of a co-pilot well
the Israelites thought so according to
the Bible God summoned Moses to the top
of Mount Sinai there Moses was given two
stone tablets inscribed with the Ten
Commandments these tablets were to be
stored in the Ark of the Covenant God
gave Moses very specific instructions on
how to build it make an arc of acacia
wood two and a half cubits long a cubit
and a half wide and a cubit and a half
High overlay it with pure gold both
inside and out and make a gold molding
around it then put in the ark the
tablets of the Covenant law which I will
give you
yeah Cupid I can't even convert to
metric don't expect me to convert to
Bible it was a little smaller than three
foot by five foot and then God give
Moses one of those little wrenches like
you get from Ikea I doubt it yeah that's
too bad those are really helpful they
are but can I tell you about the time I
got thrown out of Ikea no what did you
do I asked a girl working there hey
he asked for a one night stand
on top of the Ark were cherubim
sometimes you'll see these depicted as
Angels sometimes as winged sphinxes the
face of a man the body of a lion and the
wings of an eagle make two cherubim out
of hammered gold at the ends of the
cover the cherubim are to have their
wings spread upward overshadowing the
cover with them the cherubim are to face
each other
place the cover on top of the arc and
put in the arc the tablets of the
Covenant law that I will give you
a Goldberg
500 pounds maybe more and God gave
instructions on how it should be
transported cast four gold rings for it
and fasten them to his four feet with
two rings on one side and two rings on
the other then make poles of acacia wood
and overlay them with gold insert the
poles into the rings on the sides of the
Ark to carry it
maybe but God wanted it to be carried by
four Priests of the Levi tribe but those
priests must have been jacked huh can
you imagine the Cavs on these guys I'd
rather not in the levite priests who
were appointed to carry the yaketa Lord
when I weak of body nor feeble of limb
foreign
the ark was extremely dangerous it had
to be kept far away from where the
Israelites camped 2 000 cubits which is
half a mile anyone who touched it would
be killed instantly if they were lucky
if they weren't lucky they would die in
agony but when we analyzed the way the
ark is described in the Bible the
materials used in its construction the
way it looked the way it sounded the way
it killed people it doesn't sound
paranormal or Supernatural actually the
Ark of the Covenant sounds like
technology
foreign
there are a few theories that suggest
the Ark of the Covenant may have been a
technological device one Theory says the
ark was an electrical capacitor you
build a capacitor by placing two
conductive plates parallel to each other
with non-conductive material called the
dielectric in between the Arc was built
this way the box was covered with gold
on the inside and gold on the outside
gold is a good conductor of electricity
the acacia wood in between the gold
would serve as the dielectric it's
possible The Arc could store and
discharge electricity according to this
Theory The Arc may have been used to
generate lightning or electric shocks
which would have been seen as a
manifestation of the power of God in
fact there's a story in the Bible about
a man named uza one of the priests
carrying the ark during the journey the
ark looked like it might fall Uzi
reached out to steady it when he touched
the ark he was instantly killed in a way
that sounds like he was electrocuted
another theory suggests that the ark was
a machine but could communicate with God
and there I will meet with thee and I
will speak with thee from above the ark
cover from between the two cherubim
which are upon the Ark of the testimony
the cherubim on the lid of the Ark may
have functioned as antennas by providing
a large surface area for the conversion
of electrical energy into radio waves
the gold coating would allow those waves
to be transmitted more efficiently and
there's a theory that the arc used
nuclear power that contained radioactive
materials such as uranium which is bound
in the area when uranium undergoes
nuclear fission it releases a massive
amount of energy in the form of heat
light and radiation this energy can then
be harnessed and used to power various
devices or weapons
when the walls of Jericho came down it
was said to have been caused by the
sound of the trumpets and the presence
of the Ark according to this Theory the
ark may have contained a radioactive
substance that was triggered by sound
waves that brought the walls down
also the priests who carried the ark had
to wear a metallic breastplate and a
metal apron not unlike the lead blanket
used when you get an x-ray
metal close hey I'm telling you these
guys reject also whenever a priest
approached the ark he had to have a rope
tied around his leg around his Jack leg
this was in case the priest died his
body could then be dragged away from the
ark there's even more evidence that the
ark was Radioactive in the book of one
Samuel the Philistines and Israelites
were engaged in a fierce battle the
Israelites brought out the Ark of the
Covenant believing it would bring them
Divine protection and victory in the
battle but God didn't command this so
the ark didn't work the Philistines won
the battle and took the ark to their own
city ashdod as soon as the ark arrived
people's skin became infected with
painful tumors and it was so that after
they had carried it about the hand of
the Lord was against the city with a
very great discomforture and he smote
the men of the city both small and great
and Emirates broke out upon them
M rods are tumors that sound a lot like
radiation Burns then illness swept
through the city that sounds like
radiation sickness the Philistines
believed that the ark was cursed and
moved it to another city goth but the
tumors and sickness continued then they
moved it to ekron the tumors continued
finally the Philistines set the ark back
to the Israelites along with gold and
incense they sent therefore and gathered
together all the Lords of the
Philistines and they said send away the
Ark of the god of Israel and let it go
back to its own place
when the ark was traveling it was set up
in a portable Sanctuary called a
tabernacle this was an elaborate tent
made of woven fabrics and gold the ark
was always shrouded it was too dangerous
to be gazed upon when the ark was
returned from the Philistines some men
got curious and looked at the ark when
they weren't supposed to 70 of them were
struck down by the Lord if Indy says
don't look look
[Music]
for time the Israelites experienced a
period of peace and stability but the
ark remained a powerful symbol of the
Israelites Covenant with God and their
faith the ark was eventually moved to
Jerusalem where a temple was built the
ark was then placed in the holy of
holies the innermost chamber of the
temple the ark remained there for over
300 years and it played a central role
in Israelite religious life and then
suddenly it's gone
thank you
in 587 BC after a 30-month Siege the
city of Jerusalem fell to the Babylonian
Army the Babylonians then looted the
Temple's treasures and burned the
building to the ground the Babylonians
kept meticulous records of everything
they took from Jerusalem and even though
the Ark of the Covenant was stored in
the temple it wasn't on the list and
that's where the ark disappears from
history so if the Babylonians didn't
take it who did and where is it today
some people think the answer lies on the
infamous Copper Scroll when the Dead Sea
Scrolls were discovered most were made
of Papyrus and contain religious stories
not found in the Bible but one of the
Scrolls was very different it was made
of copper
according to our country Jim Barfield
the Copper Scroll does not contain the
word of God the Copper Scroll is not a
Bible story on that copper they have
hammered instructions to find treasures
from the Temple of Solomon which I
believe includes the Ark of the Covenant
Barfield believes that while the
Babylonians were attacking the Treasures
of the Temple of Solomon were quietly
taken out of the city among those
Treasures was the Ark of the Covenant
the book of second Maccabees says that
the Prophet Jeremiah did exactly this
underneath the Temple Mount is a vast
network of tunnels but even though miles
of tunnels have been explored none were
ever found that would serve as an escape
route from the temple but in 2007 that
would change a new tunnel was found that
runs from the Temple mount to the Kidron
Valley well outside the city from Kidron
the ark could have been taken to a town
called qumran this also happens to be
the place where the Dead Sea Scrolls
were found the Copper Scroll lists 64
places in and around qumran where
Treasures might have been hidden one
place is described as steps East 40
cubits long and buried under those steps
according to the Copper Scroll is over a
thousand pounds of silver Barfield found
the steps then he found another location
that describes a well and a courtyard
under the courtyard yard is buried 33
tons of polished gold he found the
courtyard he found the well Jim Barfield
brought his evidence to the local
authorities and asked permission to dig
at the site but he was refused later he
went back with a metal detector tuned to
look for gold and silver when he got
near the location the metal detector
went crazy again he asked permission to
dig again he was refused Barfield was
certain that there was a third site
containing even more treasure including
the arm using the first two locations as
waypoints he drew a straight line to a
cave in a nearby Hill the cave appeared
to be sealed shut but intentionally
Barfield then took a stone sample from
the cave entrance and had it tested in a
lab the results were interesting I
decided that I would take a sample of
this Stone and send it off to a lab in
Skokie Illinois where we had it examined
and they find that it is man-made mortar
in a common mixture and formula from
that time frame why would somebody seal
a random heel with concrete
when he took the metal detector to the
sealed cave it registered five times the
amount of metal that was detected at
qumran Jim Barfield is firmly convinced
that this is the location of the Ark of
the Covenant to this day permission to
dig has not been granted but many arc
historians believe that if the ark
wasn't qumran that it's not there
anymore they believed the ark was taken
by a Catholic military order called the
poor fellow Soldiers of Christ and of
the Temple of Solomon more commonly
known as the Knights Templar
during the Crusades a new Catholic
military order emerged the Knights
Templar from the very beginning the
Templars were known for their secrecy
and their mystery they were also shrewd
when it came to finance and politics
they convinced both the pope and the
city leaders of Jerusalem that they
would protect Christian pilgrims making
the journey to the holy city but as soon
as the Knights Templar established a
headquarters on the Temple Mount they
started digging and they weren't looking
for treasure the knights were obsessed
with religious relics and there was no
greater prize than the Ark of the
Covenant the Templars were known for
their use of caves and tunnels and just
recently a structure was found in a cave
system called zedekiah's cave and this
fortification was a guard house built to
defend the Knights Templar if they had
to escape the city Legend says that they
did indeed find the ark and took it to
their European headquarters in France
the famous starchers Cathedral and there
it stayed for several hundred years by
the 14th century the Knights Templar had
lost most of their military power but
they had become wealthy from their
banking practices King Philip of France
found himself deeply in debt to them and
in 1307 he convinced the pope to move
against the order and seize their assets
on October 13 1307 the Knights Templar
were declared Outlaws and any found were
arrested tortured and often executed but
when the Templars heard rumors that King
Philip and the pope were moving against
them they relocated the ark yet again
this time to Scotland where the knights
were welcomed by King Robert Bruce
Robert the Bruce had been excommunicated
by the church and was sympathetic to the
knights so when the nice Templar arrived
in Scotland they Allied themselves with
the wealthy and Powerful Sinclair family
together they decided to build a place
to keep the Ark of the Covenant safe
Roslyn chapel and there's a lot about
Rosalind Chapel that connects to the ark
and The Holy Land There are Templar
motifs and sculptures all around the
grounds the chapel is laid out just like
the first temple of Solomon but on a
smaller scale it has an inner holy of
holies this is where the ark could have
been kept far away from the politics of
Europe but then World War II
foreign
the Nazis were obsessed with the occult
and religious relics
Raiders got a lot of things right
not get the ruler of the Queen's Navy
it's well documented that they search
for the Spear of Destiny also known as
the holy lands this is the spirit that
is said to have pierced the sight of
Jesus as he hung on the cross during his
crucifixion they looked for the Holy
Grail the cup that Jesus used during the
Last Supper they sought the Shroud of
Turin the cloth used to wrap the body of
Jesus after his crucifixion the Germans
wanted the menorah the seven branched
candelabrum that was created during The
Exodus and of course they sought the
other object created during the time of
Moses the Ark of the Covenant
after they conquered France the Germans
engaged in major archaeological digs at
charges Cathedral and other suspected
locations that they are after France was
overrun President Roosevelt of the
United States arranged for the contents
of Roslyn Chapel to be moved to the
Americas where they could be better
defended so the ark was sent from
Scotland to New Scotland also known as
Nova Scotia specifically the Oak Island
while this is just a legend there is a
complex system of caves and tunnels on
Oak Island and nobody knows exactly who
put them there or what they were hiding
there are stories of the Ark ending up
in Rome where it sits on one of the 50
miles of shelves in the Vatican secret
archives some say the ark is buried on
Mount Nebo and Jordan where Moses died
an Irish Legend says the ark was brought
to Ireland by the Prophet Jeremiah and
is now located in a secret chamber
beneath the hill of Tara or Jeremiah
took the ark to Egypt and it's now
located in a hidden chamber beneath the
Sphinx but there's evidence that the ark
isn't hidden away in a cave or a tomb or
a secret chamber it's not hidden at all
for hundreds of years the ark has been
in a church in what might sound like an
unlikely place for a Jewish artifact the
Ark of the Covenant is in Ethiopia
in the Bible in the books of First Kings
and second chronicles is the story of
the Queen of Sheba she was a wealthy and
Powerful Queen who ruled over the acts
of my Kingdom located in what is now
Ethiopia and Yemen the Queen of Sheba
heard of the great wisdom of King
Solomon of Israel as she traveled to
Jerusalem to meet him after witnessing
the Splendor of his kingdom the Queen of
Sheba returned home that concludes the
biblical account of the Queen of Sheba
but there's more to the story The kevra
deghast is an Ethiopian text that's at
least 700 years old and is considered by
many Ethiopian Christians to be
historically reliable the text contains
an account of how the Queen of Sheba not
only met King Solomon but had a son by
him named menelik at the age of 22 and
about 950 BC menelik went to Jerusalem
to meet his father while there menelik's
companions stole the ark and replaced it
with a replica Solomon and menelik both
discovered the switch but only after
menelik was flying back home so there
was nothing anyone could do about it I
couldn't reach him because they put the
Ark in airplane
no the ark with the power of God flew
them home yeah the Church of our Lady
Mary of Zion and Aksum claims to possess
the actual Ark of the Covenant the ark
is never seen by Outsiders when the holy
of holies was built around the ark the
hallways were made too small
intentionally so the only way to remove
the ark is to destroy the church only
one priest at a time serves as the
guardian of the Ark and only that priest
is permitted to see it the priest lives
in the church for the rest of his life
now to be the custodian of the Ark is a
great honor but it's also a death
sentence priests who guard the ark have
a very short lifespan once appointed a
guardian they typically live no more
than two or three years but before they
die they develop cataracts and go blind
what would happen if someone did
accidentally say they all blind would be
blinded yeah and not of Miracles also
one bad Miracles yeah it would be very
high power
foreign
you know maybe being alone in a room for
two years uh they were doing something
else that makes them go blind don't
don't be disrespectful what's
interesting is these symptoms are
consistent with exposure to high levels
of radiation but if the ark is in
Ethiopia it may no longer be in the
church in November 2020 war broke out
between the Ethiopian government and the
Tigre people's Liberation Front the tplf
were rebels in Ethiopia then rulers then
Rebels again the Tigre conflict saw
atrocities committed on civilians
perpetrated by both sides when Rebels
approached the church in oxim at least
800 unarmed civilians rushed to protect
it they were slaughtered an uneasy peace
has been in place since November 2022
but it's difficult to get news out of
the region the priests in Aksum say the
ark is still safe within the walls of
the church but many locals say the ark
was stolen when the entire area was
looted during the conflict the priests
won't allow anyone access to verify if
the ark is or isn't there if the Ark of
the Covenant is on then Ethiopia becomes
another in a long list of places that
had and lost the arm and even though the
Ark of the Covenant is a religious
artifact our Hunters aren't necessarily
religious the search for the ark is of
interest to people from all over the
world and perhaps even Beyond it
you
oh
the location of the Ark of the Covenant
is a mystery that has endured for over
two thousand years and that's plenty of
time for the introduction of confusion
and contradiction even the Bible has the
ark behaving differently at different
times it acted like a high voltage
capacitor that electrocuted uza when he
touched it it was more like a heat ray
that boiled away water when the Hebrews
crossed the river Jordan then it was a
powerful Sonic weapon when it brought
down the walls of Jericho when it was
no walls come tumbling down tumbling
yeah
now maybe it's all those things
depending on what's needed in the moment
but then the question becomes what was
the power source if people near the ark
really did break out into tumors and
boils and cataracts and hemorrhoids
emeralds and what I say if that's true
it sounds like the ark housed an
intensely radioactive device a device
that could be tuned to specific
functions including use as a weapon but
if that's true where did Moses get it
and how did this technology exist
thousands of years ago it's been
suggested that maybe the tablets
containing the Ten Commandments were
made of uranium which exists in vast
quantities in the deserts of the Middle
East but even if they were raw uranium
ore isn't dangerous only when it's
refined is the radiation harmful and I
don't think it's controversial to say
that the Israelites didn't have
centrifuges and uranium enrichment
Technologies now about the cataracts
developed by the priests in Ethiopia
cataracts can be developed one or two
years after high radiation exposure
that's true but it's also true that
people who live at high altitudes are at
greater risk of cataracts the thinner
atmosphere offers less protection from
the sun's harmful rays which damage the
eyes the city of axum where the ark is
supposedly housed is almost 7 000 feet
above sea level making it one of the
highest altitude cities in the world and
there are other problems with the
Ethiopian clay Edward ulendorf was a
professor of Ethiopian studies at the
University of London and he said in a
1992 interview that he personally saw
the ark held within the church at Aksum
this was in 1941 while he was serving as
an officer in the British army he said
they have a wooden box it wasn't ancient
and it certainly wasn't the original Arc
every Christian Church in Ethiopia has a
replica of the Ark of the Covenant as do
many churches around the world Professor
ulendorff assumed that the ark at Axiom
is nothing more than one of these
replicas but the professor didn't
provide any proof that he actually saw
the ark so like many stories about the
Ark of the Covenant we have nothing to
go on but the word of the person telling
the story the story of the knights
Templar hiding the ark at Rosalind
Chapel in Scotland is one of my
favorites but the chapel wasn't built
until 1446 almost 150 years after the
Templars were disbanded The Defenders of
the Roslyn story will say that the ark
was kept somewhere else until the chap
was built then it was placed there now
that's fine it's still a great story but
there's no proof of any of that
locations like Oak Island the Vatican
Ireland and other alleged hiding places
of the Ark are just stories now I'm not
saying that they're wrong but there's no
hard evidence to support any of those
locations the mainstream view is that
the ark probably existed remember we
talked about the menorah which was
created at the same time as the ark well
in 70 A.D Emperor Titus of Rome marched
on Jerusalem and after a five-month
Siege the Roman soldiers breached the
walls and poured into the city the
soldiers looted and burned everything in
sight including the second temple Titus
was hailed as a Conquering Hero and a
monument was built in his honor the Arch
of Titus which still stands depicting
the miles of War carried off from the
temple in Jerusalem among the spoils is
the menorah now some have claimed that
the other object being carried by the
soldiers is the ark but it's not that's
the table of showbread also known as the
table of the presents and this was a
large table made of acacia wood overlaid
with gold and on the table were placed
12 loaves of bread that were replaced
every Sabbath what's interesting about
the table is God gave Moses instructions
to build it at the same time he gave
instructions to build a menorah and the
Ark of the Covenant and all those
objects were stored in the same place
the holy of holies in the temple of
Jerusalem if the ark was looted it would
have been depicted on the arch the
Romans knew how important the ark was to
the Hebrews they would have wanted to
steal it to humiliate the Jewish people
so why wasn't the ark there when Titus
invaded most scholars believe it was
taken by the Babylonians in 587 BC but
there's no proof of this the Babylonians
kept lists of everything stolen from
Jerusalem and the Ark wasn't on any of
the lists so if the r Ark of the
Covenant still exists the most logical
place for it to be is in a cave or
tunnel in somewhere deep under the
Temple Mount but permission to dig will
likely never be granted the site is
considered Sacred by Jews Christians and
Muslims and any damage to the site would
be seen as an affront to these religions
or worse a provocation but maybe that's
for the best Zechariah was a prophet who
lived during the time of the second
temple in Jerusalem and many of his
prophecies are related to The Return of
the Ark of the Covenant and the return
of the Ark is also mentioned in
Revelation then God's temple in heaven
was opened and within his Temple was
seen the Ark of his Covenant and there
came flashes of lightning Rumblings
peels of Thunder an earthquake and a
great hail storm
the return of the Ark happens at the end
of the world now that might sound
dramatic but think about what would
happen if the ark was discovered by
Muslims or if it was discovered by Jews
or by Christians what people would be
the best stewards of the Ark everyone
would want it but whose decision is that
to make the discovery of the Ark could
be the spark that ignites war in the
region which could possibly escalate to
World War III and the next thing you
know the end time prophecies are coming
true now I'm fascinated by the ark and
I'd love to know where it is but for now
the location of the Ark of the Covenant
remains a mystery and for all our sakes
let's hope it stays that way
thanks so much for hanging out with us
today my name is AJ you know Heckle fish
it's yellow this has been the Y files if
you had fun or learned anything do
Heckle fish a favor subscribe like
comment share that stuff is really
important like every topic we cover on
the channel today's was recommended by
you so if there's a store you'd like to
see or learn more about go to the
yfiles.com tips a special thanks to our
patrons who make all this possible you
guys are amazing and I'll see you on
Discord in the morning and if you'd like
to be part of a great Community consider
joining our Discord it's free but if
you'd like to support the channel
consider becoming a member on patreon
for as little as three bucks a month or
grab something from the Wi-Fi store and
look I'm not trying to plot but I'm
failing over to new t-shirts right so be
a mensch get ready and pick up one for a
few shackles we'll grab a chats for you
too you'd be with sugar than that too
that it that's my spiela Mazel Tov
that's gonna do it until next time be
safe be kind and know that you are
appreciated
[Music]
do do
thank you
one more time
dude